[موسيقى]
في ساعات الصباح الاولى نتوجه لنلتقي
مجموعه من الناشطين وحقوقه الحيوانات
الذين اخذوا على عاتقهم مواساه وانقاذ
قطيع من الحيوانات قبل توجههم الى المسالخ
هنا في بريطانيا
بعيدا عن ضجه لندن تقع مسالخ الحيوانات
ومزارعها توجهنا الى بلده اسكس التي تبعد
نحو الساعه والنصف التقينا كونر بريطاني
يقيم ويعمل هنا وفي وقت فراغه يقوم بوقفه
احتجاجيه شهريه من امام مسلخ للحيوانات في
بلده برنتود مع مجموعه من الناشطين
لقد دفعنا الى تصديقي ان لدى المملكه
المتحده معايير رفاهن للحيوانات هي بين
الافضل في العالم لكنها انجح وحملاتنا في
التسويق الحقيقه ان ذلك مضلل بالكامل ولا
يمثل الحقيقه كل التحقيقات التي يقوم بها
المدافعون عن حقوق الحيوان تجد الاستغلال
والقسوه والمعاناه منتشره بشكل واسع في
القطاع واشار احصاء جديد لانيميا
الى ان واحده من اصل 300 مزرعه التي قدمت
جماعات حقوق الحيوان تقارير بشانها ادت
الى محاكمه وذلك في فتره اربع سنوات ونحن
نصفها هؤلاء لم يتم التحقيق في امرهم حتى
فرغم ان لدينا القانون الى انه لا يطبق